and then there's a president he doesn't
make any decisions does he I don't know
it sounds like a rude word I would say
that Donald Trump is a there's somewhere
between three and fifty a bunch of
people in like a town hall and they
stand in corners and then they swap
corners like slacking off the other team
you'll be it's like you know Oh
Hillary's campaign that was such a
caucus of a campaign oh oh that's that
is a delegate who has been upgraded in
our pokémons everything I don't know
what it is he like your main guy I have
no idea I don't know what a delegate is
hey the super delicate kind of like you
know like Pokemon power up up and go
that's like the next level sort of thing
democrats of blue recup republicans are
bad well as a donkey be honest nothing
republicans like guns
I mean Democrats probably like gun
street Republicans and as you believe
that everyone should carry guns
the Democrats are people who are
marginally less right-wing we believe
that you should live in 1970 where all
of the politicians go when it is like
chill and like it's like a party you
know they just need to go and have a
good time
that's what college is for the best
years of your life so essentially what
it is I think is a way of completely
developing responsibility from
yourselves so you can just go what it
wasn't as it was the electors sounds
like somewhere where you should go if
you want to learn how to be a politician
like a school like a school like you go
I think I want to go into politics so
you go to electoral college is it like
we're young so you know like college is
we're like young people go to get
educated and stuff like that it's like
we're like you're long young political
people go and hang out like me friends
to politics together